I'm Susan stable and I chair could
handle this morning on entrepreneurship
for job creation
was that much job creation as the study
show comes from small businesses in the
first year of operation in fact small
businesses in the United States of
critical study produced three million
three million jobs in the first year the
first two years of operation and large
businesses in developed markets
generally lose jobs but we also
discussed the idea in developing
countries where you need to create a lot
of jobs quickly that large companies for
example in Brazil Petrobras is going to
need 130,000 engineers so we also talked
about the role of large companies in
emerging markets creating jobs we also
talked about and what's critical
obviously is education and the fact that
there is a lack of education on
entrepreneurship more importantly there
is a lack of education in the space of
innovation science technology and that
that is something which going
very important entrepreneurship is not
just about businesses like Microsoft or
hobo it's also about the guy on the
corner bakery that's created five jobs
and we talked a lot about is it in the
blood or is it something tomorrow and I
think we all agreed it is a little bit
us both but there's a huge excitement
around the idea of obviously
entrepreneurship venture capital
financing is also a critical element to
supporting entrepreneurs going forward
and so lots of opportunity lots of
opportunities for creation of jobs and
lots of opportunities for new wonderful
entrepreneurs